are we recording chins yeah we're all
dude before we use I want my shoes today
you want him you got him nice man yeah
dude gives a [ __ ] Congrats I care couple
things were mute kid hold on I got it I
got a couple things that one number you
suck the boys I hold on
number one you take it sunglasses off
and take your put your collar [ __ ]
down first of all just let yourself he
said he said one thing that's two things
okay and I will tell you this do what I
you know I you know why I can't take my
sunglasses off
you know why want to say it together or
what not stand
futures I got my exactly right he's not
taking him now my collar I try to put it
down but it doesn't go down why I I
think it's a cool thing not it's just
like a [ __ ] might my I put it down
and it goes like this and I put it down
and then it goes it goes you're too cool
yeah I don't think that is fair it's not
fair the other guys on the street and
they got their colors down and I go
what's going on and they go like this
well Chris drink of water I'm six
nothing now they're couple of things too
before we get to the sweater because I
want royalties we're not gonna get to
that for a second because this is my
thing now hold on chin I want you to go
to my Instagram I wanna I wanna I want
to show what kind of a supportive friend
Chris is and I want to get into this for
a second I want to get into this go to
my Instagram I'm here ya know I'm here
yeah you whelk now I'm gonna be in
Phoenix this Saturday celebrity theater
get your tickets guys go go to my good
just go to the just go to the [ __ ]
thing chin no no no to Phoenix to the
Phoenix yeah okay go
I can't remember now sweet what is the
first comment what's the first comment
on there hey everyone don't go to this
apologize right now and tell my fans I
did not only see me in Phoenix this
Saturday but also at the Wilbur theater
New Year's [ __ ] Eve do it will say
this I want to say this Chris I'm gonna
take mine off okay that's cool man we're
inside it's also it takes me a little
bit longer to take mine off but that's
fine dude I am [ __ ] still so young
okay you're almost forever [ __ ] I
mean you're almost but it's a 40 it's a
feeling you understand and I've just had
another feeling since I was young and
you know I'm the [ __ ] youngest guy
you know okay I'm doing so here's the
other thing dude I do what I want right
and when I have to do something I don't
want I go like this
not having it so I don't want people to
go to your show that is if you're gonna
make me say why don't you that's so
blatantly spiteful I know I know
dude I'm just gonna live in it hey did
you have a bit long as it helps what are
the emojis ahead of that educate those
are the alarms going off like bro hey
everyone don't go to this like if you
were in a building you'd be like what's
happening and they'd be like don't go to
the Ron Carlo to show and they'd be like
oh well we weren't gonna go anyway but
we'll make sure doctor now we're really
not I'm very nice to you I'm not
physical with you and you're very lucky
with that now don't sip your coffee out
of the corner of your mouth you know you
might be I don't like how tight that
collar isn't high up but we're gonna get
to that we're gonna get to that this is
a bad fit now listen or got by No is it
so bad is a bad fit or you waste in the
way no no I got a good body I I have a
good body I just intermittent fast which
is why I stay so cool against I I'm
gonna post about my Wilbur show and what
I do if you see I get it fast I'm gonna
come at you that's in Boston now we know
that that's one of my your fees that's
one of my tennis you're also mine from
Pasadena you've never been to Boston as
to the south side what the south side
you're Southie
no you're not whatever it is I'm from
the south side New Jersey I'm from the
south side of it you understand what I'm
saying
let's see you had some edge thank you
so what I'm saying is yeah in Boston I I
did and I'm not trying to brag on I'm
just dude I'm a fax guy you know my fax
guy numbers black like I say the facts
right I'm just a guy who was just coming
out did [ __ ] yeah coming out the gate
with just [ __ ] rip horn blazing with
facts okay I know okay so so um I did I
did I did five I did five shows that the
Wilbur at the Wilbur theater and it's
like oh yeah no and it wasn't even on
New Year's Eve right so it wasn't like
an extra special thing it was
I think it was like a Tuesday and okay
man okay so if you were at my show and
you also like Bryan Callen don't go I'm
sure there's some people that listen to
this podcast right that that don't that
aren't D'Elia fan and after this are are
people who there are a few well but
there are I'm objectively we know I'm
objectively not to be a dick okay he had
the instrumentation we had the
instrumentation with two different
instrumentations with due to non button
non partisan are you okay monitors right
right didn't we and and we had to see
who who got the biggest last and the
long stuff oh yeah well hold on and it
doesn't matter I want right right good
night and then I said hey Chris after
the show after I'd destroy that went a
crest and you go yeah and there was no
energy in your arms remember in your
arms you looked up at me and you went
yeah and I didn't here I go I do yeah
and I go how it's done
remember to you and I go and when you
said that when you looked at me and you
said that's how it's done I go like this
no I'll show you next time and you go
like and I remember looking at you and
and I thought and I was like why does
you why do your genes have the you know
what Australia looks like where it kind
of comes down on the side and then I up
on its countlessly it has horns and
stuff and I was like why do you have an
artist's drawing of Australia on the
front of your jeans and i realized you
pissed yourself it was a piece like why
do you have on the front of your jeans
the map of Australia right and I and I
got closer now and I thought but
patchwork doesn't smell like piss right
these camo pants yeah going on there and
you right because I gave you the best
right I gave you the biz right there
didn't I
when I talk to you and when I really
talk to you when I get Stern and when I
[ __ ] barreled you know when I get one
hand on my hip and I go like that giving
you the best right oh my god you're
going TT Australia man you are I'm going
to teach you whole [ __ ] went TT
Australia that's what happened do it
right
any to [ __ ] you up bro yeah you will
yeah cuz it comes a time when a man
decides to drop it all and stop talking
and he just he just neutralizes the
stares that right dude and you've never
have anybody never in your life had you
ever had anybody neutralize the
situation because you didn't lose sport
your theatre guy your theatre did
musical theater and you never got you
never gotten to mix up dude I've been in
a mix up man when I was like [ __ ] say
16
well they one thing with substance okay
one smart thing like what like Boyd what
area what arena tell me about the
impeachment it doesn't it's not gonna
matter it's not gonna matter he's gonna
be president and the impeachment made it
so he's gonna be president in 2020 fair
point fair point
how about that for substance hey why is
this it's like he's a paraplegic which
is good he's like this
Stephen Hawking relax you're gonna
criticize line dude I'm not gonna
criticize him dude look what I am
sweater so 10 of my arms sweaters
annoying this guy asked for a media
might hurt sales dude do you think about
that bro
[Laughter]
right bro all right and you saw a lot of
did you like this you think this I could
sell a dip to a firefighter what does
that mean that's a terrible medicine
oh my god I could sell it dick to a fire
fire oh [ __ ] man
ah good podcast buddy this is how it is
man mmm get that a doji star trying man
I'm surprised I wanted that I want to
thank G star raw for [ __ ] fitting me
yeah dad gave me this [ __ ] nice it's
cool lad I go like this the collar will
go down eventually when you get older
you lose touch and I haven't lost it yet
no okay so um one of you when is your
movie about zombies in the other movie
with that other actor next uh your
journalist yeah yeah when's that coming
out I'd like to work with those guys
which was I don't know all of them and
trouble hey Chris did you do you feel
most uncomfortable time in your life
when it's a Stallone party oh no the
youngest baby that was do it I'm the
youngest man alive dude it was uh it was
good it was good
I had fun dude I wasn't I didn't feel
awkward I thought I would and I didn't
know really cuz you get awkward now
they're all glued I was acting like was
a bunch of a cure exists I was Chris
Chris in the middle of all these legends
are there and then there was there was a
commercial and it was for autozone and
Chris because I'm in this course my
minutes
haha that's a good joke it didn't get I
don't think people really not Latino
women pretty she was like oh it was so
weird it was such a way yeah you're also
kind of young in that group too yeah
yeah really yeah they were making
legends but that's why I was thinking
like you can't be a legend unless you're
that old really right like I'm I see
we're all so nice you name a young
legend I mean uh yeah Johnny West yeah
like it but if he died yeah
now legends when they die yeah you don't
appreciate people to there how about
Stallone's art I was trying to explain
how good is ours
oh yeah no he's good he's good he's it
yeah it looks like he would I'm an idiot
you know I can't tell what's good or
what's not but that art looks like art
that would be sold for a lot of money
yeah yeah so crazy so which one you
stupid [ __ ] and hooked me up with one
of his daughter no don't be as don't
call it stupid [ __ ] though that's very
rude yeah his daughters are single and
and very cool and and very beautiful so
I don't know we'll see what happens
that'd be nice too yeah well I should
see how it goes
yeah it's a sweater alright dude you
don't have to eat fine let some [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying hey bro what's it
made of men acrylic no dude it's a
Christmas sweater man have you ever had
a Christmas sweater on we didn't
celebrate Christmas in my home
what you didn't celebrate Christmas in
your home what do you mean you didn't
have a well you just brought it up dude
that looks good on you man you should
that's the best outfit you've worn since
I've ever known you because you'll only
wear stuff that like would be in [ __ ]
j.crew catalog no yeah j.crew no I don't
have you shop at j.crew bro I have yeah
you do mm-hmm buy it from the [ __ ]
magazine or do you go in I'd go I go in
and then you see what size you like and
you go maybe and then you order from the
back no no no no I I go to James purse
thought about those so I say but I have
shopped it is Robert Jost but yeah what
about those I've shopped there no
[ __ ] done hey did your dad get you
gifts Chris um yeah look for Christmas
still what your daddy gave mom I don't
remember you know hey doing it he does
[ __ ] do this thing though I put on my
Instagram where one week when when he's
like Italian oh and he'll hug and he'll
like kiss all right see you later I'm
wrong but he [ __ ] kiss is so high
boots and my Holt and it's in my eye and
it makes me so [ __ ] mad dude and I
say dad you always kiss my [ __ ] eye
and he goes like this that's not your
right that's not your right this is your
eye and it'll kiss my [ __ ] eye and
then I'll go why don't you [ __ ] do it
here do it he's like that's your neck
that's your jaw I [ __ ] don't like it
man yeah I saw that Instagram yeah you
liked it didn't you did you like it I
don't really like stuff through you on
Instagram well I read hater aren't you
no I'm not a hater bro nubs that chick
likes this [ __ ] guy likes it no I I
don't ever wanna like said he can leave
two of his limbs tied still his mouth
likes it with his tongue he's got a
paintbrush like hey bro what are you
doing for Christmas I'm going to my
[ __ ] parents house yeah
Brian what would daddy get you for
Christmas I didn't Kang I don't think
I'm gonna get any presents you don't
think you were good this year I think
you're not were you naughty
hailer naughty were you you what what
what you have to be careful no I don't
being careful that's who I am
you know you have to be more respect
it's kind of vaguely saying it okay
we're naughty naughty I have my fingers
in the cookie jar
it's fine Neil Diamond you feel dude
it's okay dude
lifting weights you're still young yeah
do it yeah all right as a picture shred
Cydia well shreds not yeah did the Shred
zone yeah but still we're still having
some dude I squat where haven't Bice why
would I do anything resistance in the
leg area who is it [ __ ]
no no Mary where is ya bro oh oh yeah
that's right what you doing bro bro Fonz
got a bit of it you know Vaughn's got a
bit of a tail piece on dude you do we
got to save your fat asses we got the
same pants dude g-star yeah we got this
yeah he's down
hey B you know the gift that keeps on
giving and I use this every single day
ask me who my trainer is who's your
trainer brother just one I've to Robin
and Ali bro I'm talking about peloton
every morning I wake my ass up 6 a.m.
yep scroll on down to my freaking garage
you know my sweats I don't have to go to
some fancy gym I have to talk in anybody
nothin drink my coffee and I get on that
peloton I ride hard yep all right hard
30-minute class 45 interval class waited
class whatever you got they got yoga
on-demand you can do live classes in New
York whatever you want
give the gift and here's what's dope
about it be can try it ranks the gift of
worry free trial with Pelton's news 30
day home trial
they can try the bike worry free for 30
days so if you don't like it they pick
it up full refund doesn't cost you
anything to get rid of your rinks nope
can't do that ok maybe help with your
lungs yeah yep so check it out sometime
can you give me like a hundred dollars
or accessories or something when I
purchase it both I'm bike hmm I guess
dude this holiday give the gift of
peloton 4 lumen times get $100 off
accessories when you purchase the
peloton bike go to one pellet on.com use
promo code the fighter at checkout ah I
think the best workout clothes
hands-down our own I own a bunch of it
now I wear it all the time absolutely
there is it is it is it's it's active
wear engineered for unparalleled quality
and comfort it's a fact it's as good as
it gets
I've got its science all this stuff
they're your new go-to men's clothing
brand Brian
is it alright we're at all forever your
whatever you're doing man your active
lifestyle maybe on a plane maybe you're
working out you want cool sweatpants
whatever you need
they blend all that business with scum
you can look good and be comfortable at
the same time as the point all right go
to Rome calm slash fighter right now and
use promo code fighter to get 20% off
your first purchase
that's Rho and e-comm slash fighter
promo code fighter for 20% off rom-com
slash if you try they've got the
commuter collection they've got all
kinds of things pants dress shirts polos
invest everything wrinkle free
lightweight comfortable yeah you sound
super obsessed know they are absurd is
obsessive about clothing that is
lightweight but you sound of breath I
love it I love it I wear it all time
there you go rom.com slash fighter I'm
surprised he stood up and walked away
[Music]
you said like a paraplegic dude I swear
to god you start a sentence and don't
know the rest of the sentence yeah bro
it's called a mystery you idiot yeah
it's called a mystery mister man who
knows what he's doing all the time yeah
dude it's all calculated well these are
bro bro no I'm us chilling spilled some
gas on my hands but I'll ruin your whole
[ __ ] day it'll [ __ ] do I like all
day I love it
alright but you still smell it all day
yeah ah dude I'm not I'm not gonna let
you get away
gasoline Cologne yeah gasoline the two
of you couldn't it's a good thing the
internet came along when you guys were
what are you saying yeah I'd say what
else would you guys all a little stroke
e what's going on what do you think I'm
not stroking out I love you let's make
it sure I care about no no no what's up
somewhere else as well I'll tell you
something dude if you're [ __ ] the top
of your hair it's like the [ __ ] back
of a duck's ass everyone knows it and I
tell you what everyone knows it and
people go with sometimes I'm at the
Comedy Store in here some back of them
when you walk by that's what I hear
right do some time and they're like for
other dog that's what they do do it and
there's always that one gay duck that's
kind of just looking bad Brendan's duck
cool shoes you can't get yet on is there
a wooden when you what Aves you reach
where you can't get the Travis Scott
Cole ABS what age there's got to be an
age there cuz me he's my one friend
who's into issues like I am and I'll
send him like before they release I'm
like dude copy nice dude kappa nice and
lately is been like not yeah do not know
what you want take some like dude you
getting old huh i know you are an old
guy and I was like [ __ ] maybe I am yeah
there is it there is a cut-off right 40
I don't think so bro 40 nah man as long
as you [ __ ] own it from the inside I
don't know what that means yeah I know
you I don't know what that means long as
you own is that what you say yeah dude
so when you would somebody says you're
too old for those than you go like this
nah I'm not oh you say that [ __ ] so we
get it dressed up that is confident you
coordinate and you go I got this new
tattoo at 40 and then you go plane
taking off that's a plane but it's a
plane going around the world man Road
Dogg lies you know why no why did you
get a Boeing 707 a bro because it's a
small plane
[ __ ] bifocals outlook goes you can
hurt your bag deal deal what do you
think of Brian and Chris is Christmas
milord yeah Stewart it looks good man I
think this was my invention I think one
day I said dance and then you took it
who those are fighting words dude it was
fighting some resists I want some
risotto yeah you deserve it you can have
some of the money wouldn't make it but I
do do you admit one thing can we admit
what you want do it but yes tell me one
thing it's not a look I want it let's
think back a little because you have a
little bit of amnesia right so let's
think back at the end of the day what is
this a fair statement this is a fair
thing for this guy that I that I pulled
you from my rib dude is that fair that
would not be fair okay that would not be
fair but I made you when you were young
and lost no I was no I would not say
that nude cuz I would always look at you
and I wouldn't went out even when I was
coming up and I would be like Brian and
you're doing look down at me like that
but that's where you are so not a lot
but you used to be like a little more
like here and you're just getting a
little bit smaller process my spine is
good it's good it's mines doing crunch
me back I was training oh I had a no no
hold on what second man you were afraid
of what man you were training alright my
friend is a recon marine of course he is
hey he's recon take you to the next
level we're gonna do some explosives I'm
actually have a nephew that's recon
duties in a special you like a special
academy or something yeah they're no
joke they're no joke take it from me if
there's no don't you worry
because also one of the next level
where's the first level for ya do it
with the Recon man there's only the next
level what is I'm moving my neck like
this I did my cheating peddlin I had a
balance on a [ __ ] on a kettlebell and
I was like this a bad idea and I had to
go and open up this is a bad idea and I
went I went tweaked and it went tweaked
and I right ah that's gonna be a problem
for the next five days you need your on
roids we've been over they can't wait to
get on roids you're no I'm not yeah yeah
bro if you got how funny would it be if
wouldn't be hilarious for a sig I'd love
to see you know what for I'm good for
viewers - not that you need it you have
a successful podcast Thank You Brendon
to a mannequin yeah that's a really good
point that's going to shave and I'm
wearing makeup for my [ __ ] TV shows
it really belongs to me listen man
you're welcome for this it fits you nice
and tight yeah it's good we should all
combine our long locks like the Power
Rangers yeah yeah you guys are so lazy
offender haircuts and then you're you
watch but yeah the three of you are so
dead on Legos making sloppy joes wow wow
yeah you don't need to do that
locks though guys that'll be a lot of
long get over here dude you're [ __ ]
what what's the things name Cueto
in in a quite recall you're Cueto and
you're the guy and when he goes I want
to your love is that guy that's you yeah
he's all yeah the wet baby the wet baby
yeah you're the wet baby should bring up
wet baby from Toledo
Cueto that's his name oh that's Bryan
Callen that should be the new poster for
fighter in the kid is here when the guy
takes off his thing Jesus oh yes you you
a - for the third row third row
to the right right here bro
that's Brian and Brendan so gross yeah
what is a baby
very true yeah he like whispers OH
mm-hmm that's like your body Chris
that's just dude Chris has a
subcutaneous level of fat I don't bro
subcutaneous you just said I was
shredded right if I showed you the Shred
zone yesterday its sub-q hey you know
it'd be interesting if we did like a
sober October yeah like Brogan does with
them yeah I wonder who'd went out of you
[ __ ] ups what do you think honestly oh
I'm not trying to piss you off
no no no I know you're here you know
whatever what in our inner endurance and
stuff whatever competition what's the
competition Bri he couldn't even I think
he could you know and I think feels
pretty gangster about is it holding your
breath underwater knob if you want in if
you want if you want he's dead do I can
murder me in the holding a note thing we
shall have window no we're not single no
I know it's about win it I will throw is
though but I'll tell you this though if
we're talking about like working out our
a talking level and then like and then
like burning calories or whatever the
[ __ ] that's what I'm talking about yeah
and then Theo you get that dumper he can
[ __ ] push the other no it is an
athlete I can look for actually an
athlete on stage now Nicki Minaj's in
his shoulder I will actually I will wipe
his ass like this what is what's the
thing is him taking a [ __ ] you got a
real highs you got a black guy ass yeah
a lot of like eye stuff dude wide nose
big ass do what try my best
you can't I used to be on dunk right uh
yeah not well but yeah really it's not
really yeah that's all that aspect
really
it's [ __ ] cheek baby yeah yeah a lot
of my [ __ ] calves are in my ass yep a
lot of your calves are in your ass I
think a lot of my calves are in your ass
- I don't know you don't forget zero cab
Ryan is the biggest caster really oh
yeah you do have good care yes yeah
you've gotten talking about his calves
in this pockets for like four or five
years they've gone down since we started
yes they've gone down in an amount yeah
you leaning out your calves mine yeah
bro you gotta start going though you're
gonna not exist me no no no um we're I'm
up in my workouts now does he exist does
he just now yeah do you exist now I said
no I'm the only getting stronger and
better right uh-huh
I'm only growing you only could school
baby see can I ask you a question
maybe you guys all have you ever had to
do an acting thing where you were
embarrassed in the middle of the scene
like for what reason are good to do like
you I can't go into too many details but
yesterday you want to I've never done
this in my life I had a scene and I had
to I had to sing I had like get caught
up in the music turn and sing to the
girl I'm dating oh well and and I and
they threat to Kate come on over and
Chandrasekar who's [ __ ] awesome and
he comes over and he goes um no let's
try it a little bit what's going on
shred it and I was like and I don't know
what was going on with me and I was like
okay and then we they would come again
I'd do it again I go and I go like this
a girl like a Z and and for that hey can
we go what's going I go oh my god
I got really embarrassed this is
embarrassing speed and I don't want oh
my god dude that's right laughing so
hard cuz he was embarrassed by it and we
were all like I was like just don't make
me do it I can't I'm not this not what I
would do but like they had a concert me
sing it along wait my character wouldn't
and eyes off you remember that I
audition you help me on it was for a
John Cena movie and I freaked Wells's in
it and I have to sing you have to you is
suppose to be a big guy put down this
little girl and he sings opera to her oh
you know I've been gonna main casting
that's Brian goes do just sell that make
sure you know that it want it just sell
out don't hold back yeah yeah he's right
go in there they're all sit around the
table like now and I'll see you but see
on the wait in my car I go and I did the
whole opera thing I see the direct go
Jesus yo you wanna gang us we're good
yeah I was so embarrassed I didn't tell
you how it went I didn't tell anyone
I just watched other girl that's not
happening director was probably Jewish
dude if they say Jesus doesn't [ __ ]
she's two of the worst things I did I
had to play James
it was role for jobs yeah it was for
James D and he did this I do this opera
I mean I'm Shakespeare piece you were
auditioning what the sausage it was
supposed to play might eat the life of
young James Dean your lamb right that's
the life of young James Dean and I had
to do and there's a scene in the movie
where he does a thing from Shakespeare
where he's got a cry and it's like these
like whoa you had to be James Dean and
him doing James beer dude how about this
this gets better I worked so hard like
three days I want to happen here can I
do it and I'm like for our welfare out I
don't know what it was and I have done
oh I have done all I can
and I go as I lean against something and
I got this and I go like this and I
think I start to cry and then and it
with the gasps America's oh oh because I
think you're doing the wrong part no no
you look like James Dean I never look
like James Diaz bad idea I look like his
buddy that doesn't get laid so I so mark
mark or whatever and I'm like oh and it
was literally like two lines [ __ ] and
they just take it in the hallway and
come back in oh yeah that [ __ ] is [ __ ]
that's so funny
that that [ __ ] is so embarrassing but
wait with the school thing was it
supposed to be comedy or were you
supposed to be getting into it because
it was comedy no sounds like one is a
great episode it's a great episode I
can't wait it's actually a great episode
I get to sing it's hilarious it was just
the end was very heartfelt oh yeah I
yeah I have trouble with that my
character is kind of a hard guy so then
I'm just as a person I'm not very
sentimental and if your wish comes to
singing you're so when it comes to
singing you're all going yeah yeah I'm
outgoing no III think yeah well there
would be like bits but like with
multi-camera it's tough sometimes too
because you know you've done it but like
I like this biz talk you're gonna do
well this talk we should in the biz it's
more embarrassment talk yeah I gotta say
I appreciate you saying that because I
[ __ ] won't do that okay you guys said
that you're right and I won't do that
knowing you owned it respect yeah I own
it dude apologize too I will say I'm
sorry about that man you will say it
please just say one of my car keys fell
oh that's all good but yeah I don't like
that man I used to have a buddy [ __ ]
that would like every time we were
walking and talking with other people he
would like always like walk a little bit
over to me and I'd be like on the way to
school and I hate that [ __ ] and you
brought it up thank you for making me a
a person in a serious and I'm not sure
when Rogan would dislike somebody we'd
be out like this and he'd uh somebody he
just would say something shitty yeah
I've never seen it like when he was
young man when he was an angry yeah he
would go like this he go what oh that's
hilarious you know me I hate that I
don't like him oh yeah I don't like him
yeah [ __ ] Joe day he called me cuz I've
decided to be nice to people
really how did he do it yeah he's
working on it man I'm just saying like
because I like I like that kind of [ __ ]
and I will never change what do you mean
do you like what I like when people tell
me what's up dude ya know and I wanted
to let the people know and I want people
to let me know yeah you want clarity
yeah we all I don't want like this [ __ ]
we all do yeah I don't get it though
like some guy I was I let him know about
my [ __ ] bro oh yeah
launch is over my go sit by the window
in zero we're gonna find the kid oops
you interrupted me yeah now the danger
in that is you don't get a jewel right
well the danger in you interrupting me
is if you don't let Daddy drop a jewel
right now we all like George this bad
yeah yeah people are dying exactly a
deformity I'm gonna [ __ ] give you
some hot hot heat if I'm gonna give you
a [ __ ] lasagna of a conversation and
you go this one thing
oh right because you're not good
give us the hollow zhonya's oh no it's a
Boomer apologize no I'm not apologizing
for Schumer as I forget it now let me
[ __ ] remember what it is and everyone
be silent until I [ __ ] remember what
it is
keep tell the quiet no I can't remember
no [ __ ] dude those hot lasagnas gone
dude no such lasagnas so good though
yeah I love it hot so initiation
I don't remember nope it's not there we
lost the joke it's slippery bro I better
wasn't into me I mean I think I did me
good I don't think it was gonna be
here's the thing though you know what
you're like I forgot I was gonna say and
then somebody says then it wasn't
important I disagree with that whole
thing I forget important to [ __ ] yeah
I'll forget really important it's not
like I forget most important [ __ ] you
know why I'm trying to [ __ ] block it
out because was so goddamn important and
it's affecting my life yeah we know
what's up buddies man I don't love to be
in you know everything's good you know
we've got it you know always the oh I
got it yes yes dude this is what it was
I was at the [ __ ] Laugh Factory and
yeah the girl who takes the [ __ ]
great pictures live John so not to live
she was taking a picture second I got a
picture you and the so sweet righteous I
can I get a picture of you and your Jack
and I was like sure enough the sprite
jacket you know I mean shit's dope yeah
so I put it on and she wanted to [ __ ]
take a few shots and the flash is going
off and I'm modeling you know what I
mean like I don't know what I'm doing
but I know what I'm doing you know what
I'm saying like I'm like I look like I'm
like yeah but he's a [ __ ] he's a
funny accessible guy but really though
dude
I have steel looks that I can give the
camera and almost break the lens okay so
I'm [ __ ] doing [ __ ] you know I'm
modeling like I you know so I'm I'm
modeling and [ __ ] and it's
I'm hitting different poses and [ __ ] and
some guy says hey the Chris if the shows
going on do you mind if I get a selfie
doing modeling and I go look at him I go
like this I did that I didn't even know
I did that but I go like this ah
and I [ __ ] waved them off it goes all
sorry and I [ __ ] hit a few more shots
back pack pack pack pack pack and they
say hey man sorry about that what did
you want I told him what's up in the
moment and then right after that I was a
nice guy yeah yeah I want people to do
that to me where you just know I'm just
saying no I'm just give you a jewel but
you interrupted a borrow slice what I'm
saying that wasn't a jewel you guys are
misunderstanding with the Joel 1 I'm
sorry sorry [ __ ] like what are you
say when you want to be a jeweler bro
what I'm trying to say is oops to all of
you but what I'm trying to say is dude
do you got a junky vein
sometime right here's what it is would
you I want you to give me the business
when I need the best yeah okay I'm gonna
give you the business when you need the
business right you gave me the business
when you were like stop closing me out I
was like that's the business so I
[ __ ] opened up on you because I felt
bad and now we're back to being friends
but you got a blue I know I you daddy
why we shoot my specials and mostly use
the right side all right it's distract
the only guy with a varicose vein in his
[ __ ] forehead and you think that that
makes me happy right under your eye all
right take it easy look 25 people are
gonna see this [ __ ] podcast
hey way more than that and you're making
the vein more pronounced when you yell
Devane down dude that's my Cueto
that's your pervane missing oh sorry
here I'm gonna allow yeah it's in
[ __ ] white male black comic is it my
first special that's when I noticed it
that's why I really notice it we gotta
shoot incorrigible from the right yeah
it's a chunk even it's fine dude I don't
care about it's fine yeah you know what
you're not gonna age well no I am gonna
age well right and you know what it's
not that I'm handsome no okay no it's
not that I'm happy and I'm willing to in
but don't say ah but but it's more that
there's that this sort of a [ __ ]
thing about me right lucky to have a
[ __ ] smidgen of that thing when I
walk into a room even if you're looking
staring directly at your [ __ ] dark
wing ducks clock or whatever the [ __ ]
this is right I'm doing a thing Bauman
clothes yeah but if you're just staring
at the darkwing duck clock and I walk in
the room that way you go like this and
you don't have eyes in the back of your
head right even though it looks like you
might though when I was not hair there
yeah did you get eyes tattooed right
over like no fair shirt so I feel you
you have it you have an essence yeah
yeah you go like this the hip factor bro
from the back you run a Quiznos oh look
that way again I'm not even joking dude
look at your legs get a little thicker
they're getting a little thicker dude I
do squat you got some ham easy you turn
into Carrot Top kind of a lot of people
say thank you do it I would [ __ ] do
that in a heartbeat in Vegas just look
at all [ __ ] hey as well as what
Where's Waldo and Where's Waldo an audio
Jane just making a [ __ ] here's my
invention Where's Waldo on audiotape
I'm Bill I'm Frank I'm Waldo found him
who's ever seen the show
is selling a good way funny guy when he
did that I laughed my [ __ ] show it
was [ __ ] interrupt is my show alright
yeah it's called Floyd's do you must
have to go sleep I love you guys cuz I
love you guys man
we know what I'll do I love you guys I
don't think that's it I love to you and
you know it's [ __ ] like Rock of Love
welcome for Chris's effect
[Laughter]
[ __ ] man Oh that'd be awesome they
compete for his affection cuz he's not
into anything but I know you DePalma d
common shoes and coffee yeah come with
shoes and coffee that's where we'd be
right yeah but then that has a satiation
point and then what else massages I
don't like massage you've never had a
massage don't like him I saw here yeah
yes get him all the time man not a v8 I
go Far East on my back yeah yeah yeah
you you know what you are that makes so
much sense that you get so many massages
I love you seem like a guy that would be
like once I get some money man
you get rubbed all over time I have some
seek on my Obama bring out to the butter
man he's have a dip in a vat all over my
back man I want to member Sargent
different parts of me that's what you
would just my feet for five minutes and
then to spend five minutes on the back
of my neck I'm good a lot of he's Jeff
Foxworthy
you're made you get some money you might
need a massage
Yvonne worthy what's-his-name Foxworthy
Fox for the field that's you Theo von
worthy tow mater did you do any
impersonations man yeah I do that one
used to do Frank Caliendo
I I don't I I don't ever I don't know I
don't think I'm good I honestly for real
don't think I'm good at him I just do
him to be silly and like I don't like
bright eyed spend any time on me but I'm
an m1 went [ __ ] yeah you do somebody
do um I do is it it's mostly right no I
don't do any presidents I used to do
Gerald Ford a little when I was younger
but I'll do like hey imagine a young kid
doing Gerald Ford I can easily imagine
that and also I would do on the black
gentleman who's white also Morgan
Freeman you do that one yeah you kind of
sound like him anyway huh don't you yeah
you don't talk to my girl
yeah no texture in the show you know I
was watching his Instagram hey let me
just for tonight yeah I do a little
Morgan Freeman mmm but you're not that
far from Morgan Freeman right right so I
stay yeah safe areas for it but that's
good thanks
that's good yeah I know it's a good if
you're a baseball player we don't have
to [ __ ] be I'm units in like
defensive about something that I'm
saying that's a nice I said that's good
yeah I know it's good is good
we know the way you react you know
that's a huge job that's as much if I
say good job you said yeah I know it's a
good job then obviously when you were
younger you were touched and it's fun
okay that's how people who were touched
react it's all good you were supposed to
be a mom bro you guys we're at The
Comedy Store and these three girls there
and Chris is standing here and one of
the girls goes I'm not drinking right
now and finkles why skews cuz I'm on the
spiritual path Chris goes and that's
what a crazy person
oh so important to say that oh wait you
would like this you know what I did this
this is the kind of thing that I was
talking about so you know what the
comedies you know I you would you would
you would [ __ ] piss yourself all
right so we were at the comedy store I
was with like five friends that I hadn't
seen for a long time and you know how
when you're at the Comedy Store are
really any comedy club in LA there's
always like a few outliers and you're
like and they're like kind of listening
to your conversation and you're like is
this person a comedian does he do open
mics or is he just wearing a jacket you
know no I mean yeah so I was doing this
[ __ ] talking and we were all having fun
and this guy would be like huh yeah yeah
yeah and every now and then he would say
something and then he and and would
interview I haven't seen in a while like
one of my cast mates from undateable and
[ __ ] like that and he says something one
other time while we're laughing and
we're doing a bit and in the middle of
the bit he says something and in the
middle of me laughing I said who are you
but broke your English we're all rally
broke his heart that's the thing though
so you should know that like yeah just
don't have a sense of place yeah I get
to be that guy I remember just backed up
into a new room yeah if he doesn't know
who he is dude in the [ __ ] bra who
you are dude that's the first thing you
get out of your card you're somewhere
who there's new you know the learning
how to behave like I know not to I don't
know them so I'm not gonna be like I did
it once I did it once recently dude but
you can do it every now and then because
you're not that guy you understand your
and I felt like that guy was doing it oh
yeah every time that I'll do it too but
yeah I was at okay Wow okay
I'm try to be on your team note the
circles opening up yeah okay okay um I
was at Logan Paul's um home where he
does his podcast and Machine Gun Kelly
was there I love Machine Gun Kelly right
yeah he's good so he's like we're like
waiting outside to go on to the show
where they tape and he was like there
was some friends and I walked up I was
gonna introduce myself and then I got
nervous so now really just standing
there
but dude I was stranded there was night
sometimes I wanted to be appropriate
like it's obvious and I can feel
everybody's energy they know now I
there's some it's too late to bail it
was it leave you looking but yeah yeah
dude and I started getting scared like I
didn't know what was going on or who I
was I had this happen I was thought I
had this happen on the podcast on Monday
because they shoot that all the all the
smoke the MBA show no it was like summer
jam in there bunch of black guys
everywhere Dwyane Wade's there Steph
Curry's there and I find my like big
drop me in there and I'm in the circle
they're all o'clock and I didn't know
what this whole know and so I went what
urban with I went man no wait man those
wings oh oh man and those wings are off
the chain oh wow dude I've never said
the chose wings are off the chain in my
entire honey life on this earth a lot of
people go bird when they mean brother
wings off the chain I hate you Brenda
funny man no one acknowledged it they
want it I learned my lesson so I went on
the white guy I'll see myself oh oh my
god wow I was out I was 14 at boarding
school I just moved house kid my parents
are in Saudi Arabia still I want to be a
football player I didn't know that I
wasn't built for full price for it it's
on your dad that's what happens when you
coming to America rich you think he just
be a football yes it's a really good
point
I'm gonna be a football player I want to
be a wrestler in football I want to
become you wanna buy all my I know I
wanted to be a quarterback you want to
be gentlemen - yes I wanted out of my
you know I would set goal so I've like
by the time I'm a senior then I'll go to
college I had all plans to be over like
no Montana does Joe Montana and it was
come here and be some yeah I did and I
and yes American dream dude go on I
should have my American dream I'm 14
yeah you're right probably 95 pounds for
real and I'm earthing you New England
the fall would be so cool I was like I
can't play football it's too cold I'm
just not tough for any so this the for
the three older guys who are like kind
of big and they were good at football
they were talking on the bus and I'm her
they were having a conversation and I
was so excited that I was I couldn't
wait to get wide excitement like there's
a good wait I was so excited and I said
I never forgot I went like this I said
yeah I feel the same way and hit the guy
turned to me and he was like this he
goes yeah I feel the same way wow he's
disappeared I got so embarrassed and I
knew that I wasn't in this group and I
went like this and I went inside like
that and I never forgot it I still
remember I went hurt my feelings so
badly
I'll never [ __ ] up again I'll never make
that mistake again line you got
in here's one try though yours I try
here's one a little different than this
then then this but along the same lines
I'm walking home from school I must have
been in fifth or sixth grade okay I'm
walking home from school and there's the
hot girls they're walking together now I
was by no means a hot guy I was the
[ __ ] kid who was late to puberty yeah
and all the [ __ ] I had [ __ ] the big
feet when I was a cocky teen right oh
yeah and I'm walking with these girls
now and I'm like okay don't tell
anything to [ __ ] up this hill it's
fine peppered in some conversation
didn't really go well didn't do any
[ __ ] didn't you just kind of like a
head that wasn't good and that wasn't
good okay so I'm like oh man I'm
thinking about this um like maybe I'm
just not this guy maybe I could just let
her it's fine dude there's alphas around
I'm just a [ __ ] dork and it's all
good I remember my buddy Matt ravenna
and he was always like the [ __ ]
athlete version that he could play all
the sports and I couldn't and he was
with them too and they probably liked
him and I'm walking and I can't [ __ ]
pepper in good conversation now as this
is happening now this is all you can
take as a sixth sixth grader this is
what you can take yeah this is the
threshold okay
now what happened was there was a
pothole okay now I didn't see the
pothole all right I stepped in the
pothole as I'm already at this threshold
okay lower now my guess exactly now my
now my now my knee bends
I'd only am I already at the tip-top of
I could take the glass is full right now
I'm in physical pain and I and I go and
I go like mine like something come on my
mouth wrong way and I immediately start
leaking out of my eyes I'm crying okay
because I can't do it all right
I don't know to old to be crying so I'm
walking out details bro and you know I
may be fourth grade I don't know I don't
you already said how young does he have
to be for you to enjoy the store yeah
so so I start crying and I'm like oh my
god I'm so insecure that I'm crying all
right and I like who gives a [ __ ] now if
I go there all right it's time for
instead of my knee what's up right now
I'd be like aha Oh what's wrong I have
pursed up my knee you wanna [ __ ] you
know what I mean that's what you gotta
go with Jesus
even if you're married with kids you got
to be like hey let's [ __ ] so they know
this guy means business
yeah yeah we read you wanna [ __ ] yeah %
dude you meet - the person is right next
Lowell no no no no no you don't meet to
it okay all right look man anyway so I
start crying now that's not the good
part Shh the hottest girl senses
something's wrong which is horrible
right so she says hey are you okay
which is worse cuz I'm crying I busted
my knee I don't know how to [ __ ]
pepper in with the conversation yeah how
could she not know that you're not okay
there's so many clues what I didn't want
to be like well I didn't know what to
say in the conversation and then I
hyper-extended my knee and I feel so
insecure because you probably like
mattre venon right as you should have
said it is what I should have that that
what did you say but what I said was I
didn't toner my pen what I said was it
always a mystery what what I said was my
grandma died ah I like makeup my grandma
died oh great and now I think I have to
wait for my grandma to die so so it like
can make sense she and updating you
though no I don't even know who it was
it was just the hot girl oh but I made
up that my grandma died and I know
what's my mom did well under pressure
though you think that's good that's
creative it was creative it's not that
creative it's an easy out person that
yeah everybody has a grandmother
first thing are basically the human
version of the hampster hi
everybody has a dead one my
great-grandmother died I should have
said my great-grandmother died because
she was dead right how do we learn right
I know I'm still young I could use it
but do not know from fricken yeah dude
our one time into hollows okay I was
interested in sorry I was interested in
this woman right this adult
probably I don't know anywhere from 22
they forty how old are you to be I was
19 I think or 7 or 19 or 20 no she was
20 if you were 20 but anyway but I was
real real nervous right and she was
walking mm-hmm and so I started walking
right and I was gonna I told my buddy
I'm like hey i'ma go talk to this lady
right and so next thing you know I've
walked like five blocks I'm behind her
getting closer but I'm too nervous to
like talk to her and then uh and then
finally I get up close to her and uh and
the first thing I said at this point I
think she knew that I've been following
her for so long I was like hey I'm not a
stalker I'm not oh that's a good thing
to open with yeah hey I'm not trying to
do is what stalkers do yeah and then she
[ __ ] literally ran off this I'm not
weird it was it was a little bit uphill
it was like second Street yeah I'm
friendly with those guys that dead said
put me in my place those four bears i
sat there I felt so bad then I turned
back around and I looked at a mango when
I get older I'm gonna come into your
house when you're sleeping and I'm gonna
cut your throat what you said got older
and I made my first money on MADtv huh I
hired a dude from New York to come in
and kill their entire families Ryan I
know it's not why you guys meeting can't
jokes on their back okay but now this
cops you're making listen to well that's
in and let him let him prove what I know
you tried trumping all of our stories
with that thing yeah I don't think you
slit you hired a guy yeah to slit his
throat
for just kind of making fun of you in
the back of a bus killed everybody you
got to take your own life dude if you
really mean it that's right let somebody
else is the old [ __ ] yeah now these days
you get so angry at somebody you [ __ ]
take your own way just you just cut
yourself and bleed on them
yeah whatever your little [ __ ] boy guys
you take your own life dude about any of
this don't be a [ __ ] you guys are a
three pack of [ __ ] boys
hey girl this girl hot you burn high
school is the worst it's the word most
impression with a girl goes hi how are
you and I go hey I'm great how are you
look at this hair it's amazing I'm touch
her and she goes like this I see her go
I said she's a girl
my hairdresser all in though I stroked
her hair that's not normally if she was
taught how I remember what so you'd be
like hey what's up sprite we had a
campout when I was young so this aw man
that we all knew had a son that was our
friend and he would say your friend say
cute that's not how we met that's not
how he that's okay yeah so we would do
they had a house or television the thing
you would use to get DirecTV but back in
the day the big big one people yet but
when it broke he could [ __ ] swim and
I'm talking about the huge we had to go
out there and push that [ __ ] right two
people had to push it and one person had
to sit inside and so you could see tits
on Cinemax oh yeah so anyway we have to
leave that window open anyway it was a
blast but so one night we had a campout
out there and they had this girl man
named Emily Baumgartner and she looked
like I mean she was almost like look
like a pony
beautiful yeah from like I mean hair
from decades and centuries it goes on
nice hair the actual Amazon here from
the [ __ ] roots of society was a
nation cutting hair that had the [ __ ]
the Earth's crust in it you know what
I'm sayin Road yes in any way bro we
were sitting around playing spin the
bottle at night oh yeah and uh I'm AP
and I thought that she liked me I had
this weird sense that she cared about me
right and so
creep-creep-creep okay sure oh and I
rise to write her [ __ ] name right
here on my skin
hey Mark Wahlberg from fear well anyway
so it came timing the bottle got on one
of us and we were playing though dudes
you
port man were the numbers it doesn't
matter like five people all right cool
right we were there be group two there
was a group of like better-looking kids
my spin-the-bottle inner circle and then
you were in we didn't have a bottom they
got the bottom we got like a two-liter
taillights of sprite in it right so
anyway it laying on her and she's like
I'll kiss he hit Theo and I was like
yeah bro
everything that I ever wanted in my
whole life was just climbing up and down
my neck yeah brother gravel just [ __ ]
tickling my [ __ ] inside of me yeah okay
skinemax on the on the kissing show
where people open their mouths when they
kissed oh yeah and in my mind I'd built
her up to be like this goddess you know
she knew all about sex and everything
she and only thing were [ __ ] children
you know so I went in like mouth open
that's what I do still CPR as wide as I
could from everybody yes yeah every
that's exactly what somebody said I
[ __ ] got onto her face and somebody
goes he's trying to eat her oh I swear
bro and it [ __ ] crushed me dude if
everyone started laughing probably
[ __ ] up the whole mood and it was my
one chance but my whole life is gone at
that moment of like a attractive girl
like him before and after that in your
life yeah there's the moment there's
before and after that and that's why you
do stuff like get defensive when I give
you a compliment it wasn't really coming
it was like you kind of offering me a
compliment if I wanted it okay well I
like your bracelets thanks man
I don't have any babies are you learning
English I like your bracelet bracelet
yeah well I don't
I like your bracelet I want to start
wearing jewelry but [ __ ] talking
about him your girls on wrist where it's
the first time I've seen him with wrist
wear no he's wearing it still he wears
know that yeah made of a myth see oh
dude the Native Americans you have any
Cherokee in your some I'm one-eighth
Thursday there you go so I'm just enough
to [ __ ] is that your [ __ ] inside of you
huh huh
I felt that you know he was just kinda
hunting man he was on an open range dude
I will [ __ ] cut your body good yeah
that's great but I'm beefy though but
I'm beefy huh yeah that was agree with
you you're not beef I'm not beefy the
one thing you're not is beefy you're
tall shrim shitty dude no no you're like
you have you have loose joints I don't
your yoga right wouldn't you say but
you're more prone for an accident yeah
oh yeah baby oh yeah but that's fine
dude you live and learn it's not that
fine dude if you get in an accident I
let that hang out there because you are
there so how it felt heard you know what
I heard I heard that day about that
accident like I didn't hear what he said
mm-hmm-hmm you and that's on you I don't
remember what I said speak with
conviction you know that means I told
you what I said
there you go yeah that was like him
learning English that was like how you
kid I do this thing though and I don't
hear somebody I have a [ __ ] thing I
do I love figuring [ __ ] out you know you
don't yeah yeah I do dude he really
doesn't always it really it's like
watching a complete talk about how many
coffees does he have here's a backup
coffee dude that's my father yes
understudy call buddy calls you every
day
cuz he has like 50 ask me again man you
guys what you say how many coffees do
you have a day
all of them I do this I do this new
thing if a dude if I'm driving by and I
see a Starbucks
giddy up you turn I get a coffee a
beauty yes like this no much care about
the kind of coffee you'll do commercial
big I don't give a [ __ ] as long as his
car you're gonna be Precious about
coffee bro you pissed me off it I
impressive he's sobering is that bird
yes it [ __ ] get who gives a [ __ ] bro
its coffee yeah [ __ ] drinky little
[ __ ] yes you're on
in any car he went to spine I was gonna
say Swan but I decided we use away our
Swan I'm gonna say sweet something I
like you original eyes-u eyes-u no I'm
sorry did I'm being me and you even
though I want to be mean to Chris that's
always that's the holidays though you
know at all yeah it's true man I'm not
being anybody dude I love you guys happy
holidays happy holidays boys and I think
you look nice in that sweater dude let's
all say one nice thing to each other
okay all right you go first
wow that was not even nice to start your
son excited about it I'll do it
see that he says that I'll do it it's
not like yeah yeah oh yeah let's do it
yeah I'm fine you go first okay
you have to say something and you have
fear about it you have to say something
but now you're not getting off to a good
start on this nice car no dude see
that's funny right good and the rule is
you without laughing you have to look
the person in the eyes hit really just
gets weirder yeah it's getting real
vulnerability ready go Wow amazing by
the way remember the [ __ ] Rogen thing
right push I used to do the [ __ ]
serious singing with my friends and [ __ ]
this guy brought her on Rogen it was
like I didn't get that from you yeah bro
because you're [ __ ] this guy's like
doing it on Rogen to people like oh
[ __ ] this and that and this guy's
talking about the [ __ ] thing about
how I owe you royalties bro yeah I made
you did take that back there's a nice
holiday cheer let's let's be real
questions yeah ask it I got a real
question why bro has anybody ever seen
any pictures of Brian under 20 or were
you made through 20 I have some [ __ ]
Photoshop I think Brian was artificially
created by the CIA he was made after I
things CIA there too I like that you
were made attention some pictures you
were made after I cameras you have to
say something really sweet to all of us
bro I don't realize most shells
conversations just wasting each other's
time with completely old sometimes two
lesbians just hanging out happen in
Cleveland you just fill the air with
[ __ ] but Kalin wishes he could read
both sometimes I do right - I just
didn't know what you guys were up to man
and half drive you know what bro
I don't know how I feel that's fine hey
hey take longer to get [ __ ] up twenty
it could take an hour do I want to hurt
you I can't bring up a lot of my picture
Brian as a kid rolling back to [ __ ]
1930 the new vaudeville like hey okay
more - you guys are freaking animals man
and I love it Chris you have to say
something really sweet about each one to
do that yeah yeah yeah we almost let him
[ __ ] talk it you know where their
true alpha like this all dude am i right
give me another one to do what I'll do
it okay well we got to find it
organically but yeah well [ __ ]
finding your little piece of [ __ ] it's
good get there you old but who are you
talking my you got to come harder than
that that was like you're like old [ __ ]
but he's big though so he can come over
don't steer yeah yeah that's true
was good Brian you almost hit the
[ __ ] mic in your face there I that
looked pretty [ __ ] yeah don't even
know what you're doing with your
microphone today but yeah yeah sweet
throat [ __ ] whoa
okay that's rough those two are in the
pan there I am
why that's Photoshop it's hunter percent
Photoshop you know how I know that's
Photoshop you know I know that's what
that girl I met the other day she's that
age yeah
check out the bangs on Becky yeah that's
patty drink oh my god Brian you were
beautiful young man I was a cute kid
you're a handsome guy man yeah well look
at the [ __ ] in that boy hey now that
right there on the on the left right
there you're going over my act right no
no those are that's mice no yeah well
give press-on eyelashes that photo that
long did you get the brows too yeah I
could see bro you know what you were
doing there you are you know you look
very similar when you're young are we
dead fair and then you guys might like
this yeah we really did you uh built the
same and everything you guys were
exactly crazy
see there right there I want a pieced
you the [ __ ] up bro you were [ __ ] a
hundred and twenty pounds or your
soldier 140 huh that looks like Oh and
hard a little bit too who is that
skinny I would have [ __ ] I would have
you know what I would have done
scratched you up oh to scratch through
the just playing around that's great
young pictures of you they don't exist I
burned them all I've seen his yearbook
and it's a lot of a pigeon
I see his yearbook and I saw a photo a
scrapbook of his photos and it's a lot
of him in a musical yeah I didn't use
all boy what a musical yeah I did ever
seen a musical by the way there are no
what [ __ ] you gotta sing him again you
know I do I see him I [ __ ] see him you
know what sucks plays [ __ ] plays
musicals that's where it's at man who
done plays yeah I [ __ ] with music what
music when I go out there and I centavo
I did dude there once was a man who
served a term as office wait when
attorneys for a man you know he cleaned
the windows release ripped off laws and
policies of the handle carefully that
now in the rule of the Queen's IV that's
HMS pinafore [ __ ] y'all dude
oh yeah dude hey man I put a side window
advertisement right in front window and
all of a sudden success coming out of
the blue Little Shop of Horrors you knew
what you know you know when you did that
tough there was so much spit gathers
that's me passion dude oh these Newsies
I don't know that one what other
musicals did you do you [ __ ] we're not
American Greece but Guys and Dolls would
you bring a fork you know I played fly
him - Nicky dude I didn't go mainstream
know you played Kim a clip like can
Nikki do it wow wow yeah dude yeah
really yeah everyone 'red I was not a
nerd bro every picture was this nerd
this gangly nerd just like oh like every
picture shows up in the Amazing
Technicolor Dreamcoat yeah yeah [ __ ]
that was not good you don't know bro see
you know why I've seen it a lot I've
never liked it you Jesus Christ
Superstar tonight and Jesus Christ
blasphemous superstar Gigi West Side
Story oh no did you do the three wise
men did you do the uh like the manger
scenes I'll crack that oh no oh the
other ones that I did oh you rent out
what I really liked no but you cats no
[ __ ] that one do it I hate cats do you
ever see Hedwig and the Angry Inch no
never seen cats by the way oh yeah I
want since I was 18 I saw it on Broadway
it's not really it's bad see ya it was
just like oh my god no it's dangerous -
don't f is the pretty cool okay I got a
slip out - do you like your seat man I
love you guys Merry Christmas coming in
yeah let's get a picture of Mary's yeah
thanks let me stop it and Thea is
opening for me no he was not opening for
you man give me a boss I was here sport
you call this names and you got all
right well lucky holidays okay
land we're back so what are we doing
here you said you like guys do do she
was listening you go I'm into guys and I
obviously I'm into guys I don't care man
I'm in - oh man I tried a new thing man
I'm gonna [ __ ] ever since ever since
April of last year what guy is like what
kind of like what's your style and I
like like the like the mystery type guys
where you're like oh but they walk into
a room and you're like what's the deal
with that guy's outfit I mean of those
guys you know oh that makes sense
all right well let's do some good let's
do some coke Hey
[Laughter]
okay so this woman is a teacher she
taught in a middle school and a high
school she was recently charged for
sending one of her former students News
the nudes through snapchat she was also
Miss Kentucky at one point and her
excuse was that she was trying to send a
nude photo of her through snapchat to
her husband but accidentally sent it to
one of her students and when he
responded she freaked out and sent him
more no she's full of [ __ ] obviously be
better at lying but also when she
deserved to go to prison for three years
now percent a teenage boy how old was
she said it more what he's a honey yeah
15 oh thank you Friday 9:00 that kids
probably debits for the rest his life oh
yes he's jacking the tuna for yes here's
the thing she sent it through snapchat
why does she have her students down yeah
well that that's weird yeah let me see
her body look dude if I'm 15 that's an
and this history teacher send you those
tits yeah you'd be so very strange to me
though it's an awesome weird thing to do
wait hold on wait she won an award
strong core she weighs 2014 Miss
Kentucky that's a strong core Kentucky
not exactly that
alright man you said that I heard you
the seventh time and I've ignored it
it's just a strong core but hold on a
second
how did it come out like how did they
the boy's mother ended up finding it
[ __ ] finding it what do you mean it he's
that shot goes away right how they he
probably saved it you can screen record
take screenshots well you got to know
that that's gonna happen
some people [ __ ] yeah you say it says
teens pantry poorly found the photos up
on his phone which he saved from
snapchat also mom could be in a [ __ ]
block who knows where this would have
went you know am i right fellas
why have your student why have a 15 year
old white yeah the whole thing is just
you sent a picture years in jail it's
weird it's it's it's weird when it's a
girl
hey hold or girl Takashi 69.2 year I
know I heard drug trafficking [ __ ]
my spare seat a murder but then he
snitch yeah but dude it's just a deed
yeah yeah I got you I got you I got you
yeah but if it was a guy to a girl
that's great way work that's different
that's the world though innit that's
weird is it yeah this weird man what
girl anytime any girl dates any younger
guy I think it's [ __ ] kind of odd
well especially do what you want
115 it's really yeah but even if you're
like twenty-one and a girl's 35 I'm like
I always think that unorthodox that is
just I was like I wonder what that's all
about
it's disgusting well I don't know if I'd
go that far oh do you I thought we were
bonding on well I mean like strong words
yeah
all right so all right well what else
you got shut up to that teacher Kamiya
Cabella apparently she has a bunch of
old tweets that are here's the thing I
don't know 14 but I don't know what what
did we say though on Twitter no I looked
for them last night I couldn't find that
well let me educate you okay hit it chin
that's not why that's her right yeah she
was young so this she's 14 at least this
was she posted on her thing or teen okay
oh those are the things she posted
chicken it's basically all I maybe find
it it's all means
this one here okay damn it yeah I can't
grow long you can see him from there you
want click on them so there it is right
okay keep going
the sense is I'm not gonna say it but
said I don't want later it says the
n-word oh it's a lot of racial slur oh
Jesus Christ
a lot of the n-word especially yeah so
she would read tweet these or reblog
them I remember that remember that game
and then she put yep and then this one
good thing
ninja rhymes with ninja or this rap [ __ ]
would be hard not good so and there's
just one this one's bad it says
Rihanna's IQ is 117 can you beat her and
it shows Chris Brown's has already did
that that's a different thing
yeah yeah that one's different but the
other stuff is like this is awesome
so she was 14 she thought this was funny
you know and as you were 14 I was 14 do
you I'm not saying she should lose any
jobs I think she's 40 I would have been
people make mistake
I would even that 14 I knew I would Wike
I would have never not white I mean
she's not black she's white
no I know she's human yeah I would have
never when I was should I quit click
down the pictures but not work in those
worked not work some more out ones
worked yet are you serious we can go
back and look at him this is very
strange was 14 she was what'd you say
Chris any good footage on the podcast
just go around or we would just have a
podcast on that one but know that yeah
yeah no I
she certainly it's a weird thing when it
comes to humor like because Shh when
you're a the the [ __ ] that I thought was
funny when I was 15 yeah I don't think
it's funny now she but I never thought
race ibly don't agree with there's no
way she is 14 years old to wash only
because we better be careful about
you're talking about a real child right
God knows yes he doesn't know like you
may be in her circle that I is that
something Joe yeah at 14 we have to just
allow it's why wouldn't you kill
somebody at 14 literally you're tried as
a minor
typically and you and you
by the time you're 18 you're it's kind
of expanded from also here's the other
thing too now she's an adult she's what
22 she's done a lot of stuff like for
equal rights and for you know she's a
lot of stuff yeah you change she's like
so her features alive so what I'm saying
is if you're going to say no [ __ ] that
doesn't matter cancel her then you're
canceling somebody who does good stuff
in society different prizes in adult
oops oops right because I'm talking
right but also oh yeah video Brian horns
yeah but you are yeah you can't get 14
[ __ ] you can't judge you and based off
that old [ __ ] man
everybody makes see she being judged
right now what's going on she had up
make it up on some girls saved all
because she took this down and then some
girls saved out and then resurfaced yeah
it's a canceled culture right she's
gonna be fine yeah and she put when I
was younger I used to language that I'm
deeply ashamed I will regret forever I
was uneducated and ignorant once I
became aware of the history and the
weight and the true meaning behind the
horrible hurtful language I was deeply
embarrassed I ever want you I ever used
it I apologize then I apologize again
now I would never intentionally hurt
anyone I regret it from the bottom of my
heart as much as I wish I could I mean I
believe I go bad with time or team yeah
yeah yeah I'm 22 I'm adult I'm grown not
grown at 22 but whatever but I mean I
you know I believe it she was a kid she
was ignorant she was uneducated that's
kind of the definition of a
fourteen-year-old yeah I don't know what
her circle was and yeah yeah and she was
trying to be funny and it was just [ __ ]
yeah it wasn't
yeah we might have been different if she
was like actually saying like you
serious yeah and yes serious hard even
then I would have said you're 14 and you
were around the wrong people that's what
I'd say you know I mean if you're 14
somebody's telling they're
impressionable yeah you're very
impersonal
again you're a child so I think that you
get a pass me your kit you just do and
she's not that person anymore and yeah
if you don't accept an apology that I
don't know what the person supposed to
do kill themselves I'm aware yeah yeah
let us yet
got this from Chris Jackson of pornhub
is just a bunch of fun little facts of
pornhub in the past 20 boys hey porn up
business is a-boomin its up what how
much first of all 40 40 million million
visits to porn up 115 million bits per
day Wow and you know what the most you
know the most common will upload is the
most watch I do I do
what is it step mom well no yes no okay
not know what is it hits basic mother
[ __ ]
what is it amateur no it's not it is
yeah they want to see like boom that's
the lose Bella selfie who the [ __ ] would
do the alien one about Delphine dude who
that's the girl who was selling her
bathwater oh I don't know I'll show her
picture but all she does is when she
does she get [ __ ] in the water you
know it's literally just her selling
remember this girl she says she bathed
in damn she's making money then well
they don't really make money off those
porn sites no no she has weird like that
foods does she get [ __ ] in that tub or
no no she's not a porn it's not porn
she's just a huge troll that makes money
off of AA guys who watches oh wow
and she's the number two most searched
she's making up a bang she's done
looking for hopefully those aliens are
getting their share Dom off and on oh my
god all this money
apex legend where none of these deals to
me well not good why I'm mature and POVs
know I was pretty [ __ ] weak dude yeah
well yeah yeah true POV is cool though
right
depends who it is aliens disgust that's
weird
what is he what's cosplay like a video
game
is it possible I says wondering uh is it
possible that they point out put this
out here to push some of their new stuff
dude you are such a conspiracy theory no
they have all the numbers why would they
don't care how most searches in terms of
Japanese
hen time has been no means a 5 career
yeah stepmom stepmoms on the dude big
tits is still in there just carpe but
it's down it's down
okay look I like how they have it like
stocks like up and down keep scrolling
down with those squirts on the way down
joy joy dude big black [ __ ] up 11
nowhere
BBC oh oh I don't know that yeah keeps
going down most search porn stars ooh
man are Mia Khalifa is entering cuz she
doesn't do Newport you see her just you
just see her hips just like Jase I'm
Pharaoh you see that little [ __ ] hey
[ __ ] I got it figured out I wish I did
this the whole time
hey bro why you relax wait so let me get
mad if he's Belle Bruce Wayne why you so
relax dude bow bro these are cool cool
look Brian Rocko see from oh you like
you like him James Dean dude Bryan Cal
with Brian's names on there man bingo
still rockin boy I drink that low-carb
beer I do not feel good I don't know
anything most viewed verified amateur
models no you know I'm like you know I
looked at this chin the email they sent
us and he was like the guy centers he's
like big fan of the show he goes wow you
know I say jackin but he goes he goes
the number-one thing man is anyone can
be a porn star now because amateurs so
big
hippie were just uploading that we gotta
do that do you know what a sex tape on
there being huh what's blast with you
yeah I mean if you find the right girl
this is actually interesting
what's this name ten minutes what kind
of cycles watch out ten go down Russia
Russia's like let's get you know no
let's give you no no come on get in
there put it on put it on oh god oh god
okay look what the work time spare well
money that's all eleven ten dude
Mississippi [ __ ] taking a sweet time
damn the South is really Jack colder it
is the less they spend that people do
busy California just not on there at all
huh
favorite time watch porn where we
looking at boy midnight kind of savages
are these four pm look how high that is
whoa
who's gonna work if you wanna be
different jacket that for him
yep that's different yeah most food
category Japanese sup bro hey welcome to
my podcast
set out you guys heard congratulations
[Music]
is the neck cream also site this is one
more just one more
the cyber truck let's see if I can get
on get hard in the paint dude to go hard
you have super hard there's a knock off
I saw this cyber truck and I think this
is in Russia somewhere cool shoes yeah
I'm gonna guess you had seven coffees
you know what dude I'm gonna go sleep uh
you went hard you came in hard all right
let's not in on I mean I was just a
sports one but everyone's talking about
this jump that Ronaldo do educate these
stupid funny of course I've seen it foot
a for seen it I saw this goal of the
year it supposed to be mine as a 40 inch
vertical yeah it's an insane amount of
height that he got and there's the
actual kick and he gets the goal wow
that guy hey another Christian wow she
looks like a Premier Soccer League look
good they looked very similar to you I
should do that's how she come out on
stage and that's Brian try to block it
soccer
look at that that's just from years of
jumping huh huh well I'm done well there
you go that's it we're gonna see me this
weekend celebrity theater Chicago I'll
be in [ __ ] New York shut up you're
noisy
make sure you fly to Chicago Chicago
come to come to Boston for New Year's
Eve cuz I'll be at the Wilbur so you can
choose Christopher you can choose the
guy who came you know Chris came for my
rib so come see the real thing
you're gonna be a Chicago
Chicago I got three shows at the Chicago
theater how many tickets you do the math
you're doing one into Wilbur yeah so far
we might add another one you never know
because takes it going fast yeah is that
why you're promoting Mother paragraphs I
don't like that attitude
I'm Oklahoma City next Friday and then
I'm in Tulsa Hard Rock Casino on
Saturday their new year's come served me
at Pasadena Ice House two shows a p.m.
10 p.m. shows Ice House the next year
January I'm at Foxwoods casino on the
10th and I'm at Wilbur on the 11th
they're less than 50 tickets left
suck it Bryan yes yeah dude [ __ ] it good
bro tea fat k DICOM suck it good sucky
sucky anything else Chris you guys both
on your [ __ ] cell phone I win I win
all right dude that's the fun kid
we're out